I want to show you a picture an image
that I created collaboratively this
morning so as you see this was tagged
Danbury Connecticut so that's just down
the road and since I posted it this
morning six hours ago 18 people have
liked it they haven't told me what they
like about it but they've liked it and I
added some context there my name or my
handle is their BS carpenter I double
water fountains Danbury Connecticut 2017
and then there's some hashtags double
taking troublemaking and then I've
tagged some other folks who I follow or
follow me who I thought might be
interested all three of them happen to
be connected to MIT so this image is in
many ways just as a black and white
Instagram photograph that I also posted
to my tumblr account and I posted to my
Twitter account there's a practice
people do quite often but this is a
photograph that is that originated and
continues to exist within a conversation
for me with an existing photograph
specifically other similar photographs
as well as it's it's it's within a
conversation with other people as you
can see at least 18 people who like it
but haven't commented on why they like
it this photograph was originally taken
as a as a color photograph using this
phone I set the the setting from
portrait and landscape to square because
we can do that now we have these options
and then once the photograph was taken I
put it through a series of filters and
Instagram to turn it into this black and
white photograph now as you can probably
notice I most likely didn't shoot this
on my own unless I had a tripod and then
a timer that I set so one might assume
that someone else actually took the
photograph and that's what happened this
is the most recent photograph in a
series I believe I'm at or beyond 100 of
these in the past three or four years
in which if I'm in a public space and I
see a double water fountain and there's
someone nearby I'll ask them excuse me
would you give me a hand I'm an artist
and I take photographs of double water
fountains would you mind taking a
picture of me I'm gonna drink out of the
fountain and I'd like you to take a
picture of me make sure both fountains
in my body are in the photograph please
that's all the instruction I give them
there's no composition 101 there's no
depth of field lesson and then they take
a picture and I drink the water during
the entire time they're setting up and
moving their body and in and out and
sometimes it takes a couple of seconds
sometimes it takes what feels like four
or five days you know that you know
you've had this experience right and
then what happens when you ask someone
to take a photo of you using your camera
or your phone they turn around they show
it to you we can do that with digital
photographs now how is that and I'm
looking at zone oh that's quite nice and
then if they're if they have time
they're not rushing up oh I have to run
well would you mind looking at another
photograph and most of the time they say
yeah I'll look at the other photograph
and it's that other photograph that I
show them that inspired me to start
taking these photographs so the other
photograph I show them is this one this
is also a black-and-white photograph it
was not taken by with a digital phone
was actually taken with a camera that
uses this interesting technology called
film a lot of people who use these
machines don't actually know what film
is and this photograph was taken in 1950
by Elliott Erwitt and it was taken in
South Carolina and this photograph shows
a gentleman wearing a hat drinking out
of one of two water fountains the water
fountains
each have labels and they although are
situated as double water fountains
side-by-side fountains they are
essentially constructed for different
audiences in different users and we
might know that because of the the
labels that are above them
this photograph double water fountains
it's actually called segregated water
fountains is one of a few that are way
in the in the 50s he was a he's he used
to take he was just known as a street
photographer at that time when he was
taking photographs and capturing just
some basic typical scenes that would
happen in daily life so it's this
photograph that I had probably seen
herself one of them similar to it years
and years ago I don't remember the first
time I saw it and you know how images
come in and out of your life or people
come in and out or stories come in and
out but this one did the same thing but
about 10 years ago 15 years ago maybe
when I started wearing hats like this in
part because I just thought they look
pretty interesting and they reminded me
of my grandfather whose first name is
also my father's first name it's also my
first name so there's that connection
there and as I looked at this photograph
shortly after I started wearing these
hats I started to see these photographs
differently because as I looked more
closely at that photograph I started to
see myself in that photograph and wonder
whether years before I was even born
right I was born 15 years after this
photograph was taken but certainly signs
like this and practices that these signs
encourage were still in place when I was
born but as I continued to look at the
this photograph and others like it I
would see myself in it differently and I
would wonder would I what would I felt
like what would I have done what would
have been like for me to be in that
situation so I started to take in public
places it's not uncommon to see double
water fountains
in public places is not uncommon to see
other people in public places is not
uncommon for me to have my phone which
takes pictures so that combination of
components inspired me or has been the
motivating piece and also the the
materiality of this series of works this
is on a beach in California
I don't recall where this one is
Instagram remembers I don't have to
remember this is in the State House in
South Carolina
three or four months before the
Confederate flag that was flying about a
hundred yards away from this spot where
you see me three or four months before
it was taken down a few years ago so my
daughter who is now eight but the time
that this photograph was taken she's
about three or four and because I think
I'm a pretty good dad she I take care
take her with me into various places and
public places have double water
fountains and she would watch me ask
people to take my picture in front of
double water fountains which was all
well and good because you know that's
what Papa does he's an artist and he
does things and takes images and but one
day she asked me papa
would you take my picture I said sure I
would be happy to but you have to take
my picture
and so we gain perspectives on the world
through the eyes of other people seeing
what we see through what they see but it
more it's more than that being an
interesting photograph of this three
year old angle a few feet off the ground
there's also a moment where I realized
that the next question for her after
would you take my picture was Papa why
are you taking these pictures so then I
had to have conversations about
the history of this country and a
particular story an ongoing story an
uncomfortably challenging story in the
history of this country story that we're
still writing today I had to talk to my
daughter about race and so this project
the double water fountains project you
can find on tumblr
just look for BS Carpenter III and there
it is I post these images quite often so
I'm saying all this to say these
photographs come from my interest in and
my relationship with the double water
fountain photograph where the segregated
photograph by Elliott Erwitt this
historical photograph for me sits in a
conversation with many other photographs
like it but also within the practices
the policies the cultural understandings
that allowed for segregated water
fountains and segregation to exist if
you walk down the street of Baltimore or
Philadelphia and there's plenty of
confrontation right these last this last
year in Philadelphia that a lot of
people would feel is racially rooted and
if you say oh we should have more
constructive conversations between
people they should learn how to deal
with a conflict that's in some way
connected to or racially defined or
rooted and well people don't know how to
do that they don't know how to do that
to its cross race and so you think it's
the picture that makes the conversation
possible it's pretty harmless picture
it's not a sudden slam Ettore picture no
so the conversation begins well before
the photograph is taken the conversation
begins well before the Erwin photograph
is presented the conversation begins
well before the conversation about race
or history or wherever the direction
happens right
so your question about well how do we
engage in these conversations how do we
engage in these conversations we start
the conversations I don't know that I am
concerned that when I hear statements or
there's an assumption that oh well it's
a difficult conversation we can't talk
about it I don't I don't think that's
the case at all we can I think it's the
starting and this is I think central to
party question is how do we start those
conversations I think we need to start
it
the mediator which is also what I heard
what you were saying might be the might
be the camera in the photograph might
not be another individual third thing I
would say is and I hope this came
through with my my discussion my
description and my earlier responses I'm
not trying to persuade anyone I'm not
trying to make a case or in your example
where maybe sensing someone's defensive
not trying to you know nail them to the
wall or you know but it will prove them
wrong but rape bring up other examples
that allow us to continue the
conversation it's about opening it up
rather than saying if so for example if
someone said oh well we're way past that
no you're wrong
here's I wouldn't it's not about no
you're wrong it's oh well what about
this or tell me about such-and-such
so instead of being persuasive to the
point of arguing a point to convert
someone from one perspective to the
other while that might be at some level
a goal for some folks engaged in this
work I think before one guess they're
becoming comfortable setting a
comfortable space for the conversation
needs to happen so it's not about
persuasion it's about let's open up up
that space and talk about the
difficulties within the complexities in
that conversation so for me there's
something unusual that I think is
attributable to the photograph to the
fact that the photographs at the high
part of a conversation about race and
there's both an old photograph and a new
photograph and in some other realms
particularly in the realm of science
there are different qualities of people
from different disciplines talking to
each other and one theory about how to
overcome those difficulties is to use
something known as a boundary object so
it's not me and you and our different
disciplines it's oh here's a map and how
do you read that map
oh no I read that map differently what
do you think that map said oh I think
and I don't have to talk directly to a
person from a different discipline I can
both be talking about or through the
boundary object and my question and the
question in my mind was does a
photograph in particular and a black and
white one in particular and an old
versus a new one provide a means to
address in this case a difficult
potentially difficult conversation now I
think the who the people are matters and
I think your non-defensive style and
your willingness to track the
conversation wherever it goes probably
has more to do than anything else with
how the conversations you have turn out
but I'm trying to see if we might deduce
from your project some kinds of insights
about the use of photographs in
particular but not only to make
difficult conversations easier that's
where I'm going with my questions so
your example of boundary object is
interesting because makes me think of a
couple of different things one when
talking about works of art in schools or
even in galleries
for a number of reasons that we don't
necessarily need to get into at this
point many folks are interested in the
formal qualities of those works and
those formal qualities are fine formal
meaning you know shape and color and and
texture but as we start to look and
think about those works of art
contextually place them into a
historical context of social political
context those works are about those
other realms as much as they are about
the physicality moving it away from the
material the physical material into
other kinds of move into new materialism
is in some way so I think there's a bit
of that going on where your your example
of the map it's not about the physical
map itself it's about the representation
the signifying aspects now these
photographs the black and white
component the the the formal aspect
moves it away from and this was
intentional for me because he an
original dozen or so that I took were in
color and there was some distance for me
between those color images and the Irwin
photograph and it wasn't until I
tinkered with the first one in Instagram
and made it black and white and I
resisted it because I didn't want to be
too literal you know it there was a
shift that happened the the time element
flattened and so putting oneself in do
something about a black and white
photograph that it that moves it away
from a contemporary sense of because of
the cut the color gets removed now the
other piece there is so you know you
want to have an interview with someone
so you say okay bring an object that
means something to you or we'll talk
about this map this photograph we
produced together as a matter of fact
the person I'm talking to
they're the ones who produced it
primarily they composed and took the
shot so they have a degree of ownership
and connection with that that's a very
interesting way of reframing why it
might be easier
for them to use the photo to as a basis
for the conversation because they have
part of the ownership of having taken it
not only they part of the ownership of
having taken taking it but if you look
closely at the photograph you don't see
them in the photograph I'm in the
photograph so anything they say about it
right it's separated from them but it
gets difficult too because the person in
the photograph is the person standing
next to them so while the photograph
allows for some separation and ejecta
fication of that individual the very
subject at hand is right there so
there's a complexity there but their
contribution to the creation of that
work in that ownership I think is is is
key to - to this conversation
I've been trying since the first time I
saw this to imagine if there's a method
in here to make it easier for
conversations that I've race at their
route but I particularly mean
conversations about situations where
race is at their root and they are about
people being unable to deal with
differences in any other way except
through violence and so I want to make
them harder more difficult conversations
but I'm trying to imagine and hopefully
we can actually at some point do this
whether the same smoothing or easing
effect yes of the exercise makes it
possible to have a conversation which
otherwise you couldn't have yeah I think
so
statement that I'll use tomorrow in the
lecture and workshop but I'll use it
right now I was in but three years ago I
was teaching an undergraduate class and
students who were preparing to be art
teachers and we were talking about so
what is this art what is art do why are
we studying art why do you want to be a
teacher of art what is art role and in
our lives you know these really small
forget questions no it's big important
question and student one of the students
said you know art allows us to among the
things that it does but it allows us to
tell stories that we might not be able
to tell otherwise and we probably can't
tell otherwise yeah that makes sense and
I'm pursuing I mean people are terrible
it's just caught off guard and with no
special training trying to deal with
issues that have race or ethnicity and
many cases gender at they're at the
heart of the difference or the conflict
and I'm just trying to think of this
notion of flattening and and overcoming
history by having the two
black-and-whites
next to each other in the same location
and now not everybody is as charming as
you are and so they would not get the
same response but maybe the existence
and the fact that they took the new
picture which I haven't thought of until
you said it this afternoon is you know
they own some of this so now maybe it's
easier for them to stay with the
conversations maybe adding an artist
makes and doing these things makes it
easier also you're you start out by
saying I'm an artist I'm taking these
pictures you don't say I'm someone
waiting on the street corner to ambush
you because because I don't know if I
can trust you and you probably don't
think you can trust me none of that it's
just I'm an artist we take a picture of
me doing this and that's very disarming
and every sense of that phrase and then
maybe that's the key to moving toward a
conversation where nobody's anxieties
and prejudices gets go sky high right at
the beginning now I don't know how long
it would last once you tell them what
site is if they didn't already know it
in the model that I'm sure and they
might know it if specially if they live
in that neighborhood or nearby which
would then be quite a rich conversation
you know in unexpected ways I guess for
the artist who was initiating their work
you